you're completely worthless you're never
gonna amount to anything in life and one
day you're gonna die
anyway remember to smash the like button
leave a comment and subscribe value is a
fickle thing that sometimes makes sense
and sometimes does not burger at
mcdonald's say that's pretty cheap oh
we're dining in five guys damn that's an
expensive burger but all right popcorn
at home a cheap casual snack popcorn in
the cinema let me just take out my
second mortgage here's a monitor stand a
hundred bucks oh it was made by a free
company a thousand bucks should a monkey
jpeg be worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars
only if you have less iq than an actual
monkey but if there's one thing we can
all agree that you can't put a price on
it's
life
or can we resource music i'm sure we've
all seen that cheesy scene in a movie or
anime where the main character preaches
some [ __ ] like
you can't put a value in life because
all human life is priceless and i
remember the first time i heard this as
a kid i was like yeah well i'm broke and
my mates are broke so broke plus broke
still equals broke so
yeah i guess you're technically right
but what if you could what if all your
contributions past present and future
your happiness your influence what if
your entire worth as a human being could
be boiled down to a single monetary
value what would you do with it would
you sell it would you keep it would you
even want to know and most importantly
do you pay out in prima gems this is
exactly what three days of happiness or
i sold my life for 10 000 yen per year
explores and might be one of the most
impactful short manga i've ever read and
i'm going to talk about why you need to
as well because do you know what's never
undervalued today's sponsor boxing
boxing is a monthly subscription service
that delivers premium japanese snacks
and tea pairings straight to your door
each boxy features a unique theme that
provides you a gourmet journey through
japan snack culture one of the biggest
things i find living in japan is that
everything everything here is seasonal
and that includes all that snacks and
the exciting thing is you guys get to
experience that too now it is sakura
season as you can see boxy have provided
me with a bunch of cherry blossom themed
snacks and they all look absolutely
delicious i'm gonna be honest every year
japanese cherry blossoms bloom all
across japan during this time and people
celebrate by gathering under a tree for
hanami or flower viewings for a picnic
and look unfortunately it's really
really hard to get into japan at the
moment so if you want to experience
sakura season and hanami from the
comfort of your own home then boxus got
you covered i personally love all the
sakura flavored biscuits i get
mmm god damn that's good so if you want
to have your own sakura celebration and
support this channel then you can click
the link in the description and use code
giggup 15 for 15 off your order thank
you to boxu for sponsoring this video
and back to why you should be reading
three days of happiness kusunoki is a 20
year old guy who suffers from a deadly
medical condition
being broke working a dead-end job for
table scraps one day while trying to
sell his possessions for a quick buck he
hears about a place where he can get
some extra money a store that will buy
your lifespan time or health for cold
hard cash skeptical but well desperate
he decides to give it a shot i mean
surely a man's life is worth a good buck
how much could it be 1 million yen per
year 3 million yen total 3 billion maybe
300 000
per year no that's 300 000 yen for the
entire remainder of his lifespan for all
you hamburger eating gun-toting
americans out there that's about three
thousand dollars for the entire monetary
value of his life that's about a
thousand happy meals fifty copies of
horizon forbidden west or one five star
in fake grand order finding out he has
thirty years and three months left to
live he decides to completely cash out
and sell almost everything for 10 000
yen for every year of his remaining
lifespan leaving him with three months
left to spend it of course tell the
person exactly how long they have left
to live and they might be prone to doing
some crazy [ __ ] to go out with a bang
like playing real life gta or
immediately spending your newly required
life worth on genjin pools so to prevent
this he's also given an observer which
in this case is the exact store clerk he
sold his life to a girl called miyagi
who keeps him company up until his final
days if you couldn't tell by the premise
alone three days of happiness is an
introspective story centered around the
value of life how best to spend your
time here on earth and what it means to
enrich your own life you know just your
standard existential [ __ ] you have a
crisis over whenever you forget your
phone before running to the toilet and
slowly realizing that you're about to
have a foamless poop originally a novel
called three days of happiness this also
received a manga adaptation called i
sold my life for 10 000 yen per year a
revolutionary adaptation that broke new
grounds by having a manga with a longer
title than his light novel counterpart
from now on i'm just going to be calling
it three days of happiness for the rest
of this video because that's just that's
just a really big mouthful alright it's
a relatively short manga but it knows
exactly the message he wants to send so
we get a concise story that hits and
hits hard cause how do you even begin to
calculate a person's worth do we go
solely by what they contribute to
society how much happiness is in their
life or how do they affect the happiness
of the ones around them are we going by
current achievements or future potential
stuff like this isn't something you
normally think about and the more you do
the more bleak it becomes and for some
like kusunoki how do you process knowing
that your life is worth such little
value and now that you sold it he has a
time limit to come to terms with all of
his life regrets while figuring out how
to best spend his remaining days it's a
tale that's painfully relatable not
necessarily because it shows a guy
figuring out what he wants to do and
achieve in life before he dies right
guys
but because what we see here is a
journey of a soul that feels completely
lost look i don't want to assume what
stage of life you're going through right
now but anyone who's gone through or is
going through their early 20s knows that
it's hard to feel anything but lost wait
a minute you're telling me we've gone
through an 18 year long tutorial lesson
on minecraft and now you expect me to do
a no death run in the world of [ __ ]
elden ring what the [ __ ] are you still
making fart jokes and find uh oh sneaky
poo poo hilarious now i got to find a
career being responsible for my own life
and paid taxes what the [ __ ] is this one
year you just wake up and get tossed
into a totally new world and you're
expected to know how to adult properly
the exact path you want your life to go
and it's absolutely terrifying some of
us through trial by fire may get a
stranglehold on our own lives beat the
boss and set ourselves in a direction
we're somewhat satisfied with and some
of us never move on from that stage and
that's exactly what our main character
finds himself in kusunoki is a guy who
had goals he had ambition he had talent
but somewhere along the line he slipped
into a self-destructive meaningless path
in life he shut himself off unknowingly
sprung hurt upon the people closest to
him and unfortunately realized too late
that he peaked at the age of 10. the
more he reflects on life the more
mistakes he's realized he's made to get
there and it's his interactions with his
observer miyagi that helps him put
things into perspective she's someone
who seems equally lost in a different
way a girl that's detached and distant a
trait coming with the job that she has
and slowly but surely a bond forms from
their shared sense of purposelessness
but at the end of the day what really
hits home is that he is the reason his
life was worth so little there was no
big life event that sent him down the
wrong direction no one person to blame
for where he ended up at it was he that
set himself down this path one small
action or
inaction at a time it's a bleak and
uncomfortable way to look at things but
the story uses it to delve into a
wonderful exploration of fulfillment and
happiness and what it means to find true
wealth in your own life selling his life
is what makes kusunoki slowly find
purpose in it he reaches rock bottom and
uses it as a stepping stone to climb
himself back up he finds a meaning in
life that had none of it lives more in
three months than he ever would have in
30 years brings more happiness to those
around him than his previous lifetime of
emptiness and it is nothing short of
powerful to see it all unfold and
something i really think as many people
as possible should have the chance of
experiencing the story never answers the
question of how you determine a person's
life worth but instead reminds you that
the question exists in the first place
and in that vein ends on one of the most
beautiful life messages i've seen in a
manga sometimes you come across a story
that changes your perspective on
something or gives you a message that
really sticks with you deeper than some
things you can even encounter in real
life inspirational quotes turn into
posters uplifting speeches turn into
tick-tocks moving videos with
thought-provoking life lessons i don't
know if overexposure to the internet and
media has numbed me to the point where
if i do see something preaching good
morals even if i do fully agree with it
it doesn't always sink in there's only
so many shack motivational shorts a man
can watch before i literally start
ripping my paycheck in half sometimes
you need a story to put things into
perspective and really let that message
seep in and that's exactly what three
days of happiness did for me this is a
story that doesn't just lay out the
journey of someone else's
self-reflections but gives you the
opportunity to do the same for your own
and after i close the last page i just
had to stare at the ceiling for a while
to just
digest it's only about 16 chapters so it
only took me an hour or two to finish
but honestly i can't think of many
stories that would have given me a more
valuable hour or two the question of
one's life value is something we can all
ask ourselves no matter what age
background culture ethnicity or family
you may have and i'm sure no two people
would have the same answer but if
there's one thing that remains constant
for everyone it's that the only one who
can have an effect on that value
is you you are the determining factor of
how much value goes into your life
monetary or not tangible intangible you
are the only person who has the ability
to increase that value starting from
today and it's never too late to spark
that change because no matter how little
you may think you contribute no matter
how worthless you may think your life is
right now that has no bearing on what
it'll be ten years five years two months
from now or even tomorrow and that's a
sentiment i think some people might
really need to hear today
you